Qi Pao chicken now dress John Charlie
God some people uh you know we're
complaining they're saying that you're
looking like a ski skank exactly skank
that would be fun as if I'm skiing yeah
I would like that I'd love to see you
cold we're seeing a lot of your whoo
we're seeing a lot of your hoo-ha it's
oh did you just call my vagina whoo huh
are we there yet oh my god can I say
vagina - this is my traditional Chinese
garb we encourage you to express
yourself in whatever way even if it is a
frozen yogurt with me on the pier this
weekend it's not yeah not something you
want to even think about
I think behringer white zinfandel might
have something to say about that right
I'm saying you plus two glasses of
behringer whites in equals my special
move getting a standing ovation I'm a
powerful man
Diane tells eggy to put on slacks you
smell great you smell like lavender
that's how I say lavender yeah yeah it
mix it up I went to a friend's is that
how they say lambda you'd be surprised
I don't want to close my eyes I don't
want to fall asleep because I'd miss you
Charlie I'm Steven
so if you have any questions um this is
my number right there I actually let me
just
but my home number on the back call any
time if a woman answers hang up and call
back in 10 minutes
that's Deb she's a real